[Music]
Overland is your typical family road
trip if that road trip included tons of
monsters and some highway robbery
the premise is rather simple you begin
your journey on the East Coast and you
need to get to the west coast
unfortunately civilization is in
shambles and fungal looking creatures
have sprung up from the ground and of
course the poor souls who've managed to
survive aren't the most trustworthy of
folk part Fire Emblem and part Oregon
Trail Overland is a randomly generated
tactical adventure game that has you
traveling from area to area scrounging
for gas supplies weapons and meeting
fellow survivors
once you've looted an area you can drive
on out and continue your journey across
the United States but that sounds easier
than it is if you run out of gas you'll
end up stranded on the side of the road
surrounded by monsters if you leave your
car unattended another survivor could
steal it and you'll be forced to
continue on foot
if you get surrounded in your car you'll
be forced to fight your way out and if
everyone in your party dies then it's
game over combat against both humans and
monsters resembles a simplified tactical
adventure game each character can travel
a certain amount of tiles per turn to
gather supplies or attack enemies
unlike XCOM or fire emblem though these
interactions are rather simple survivors
all have the same based attack and
there's not a leveling system most
enemies only take a few hits to kill but
so do your survivors this makes
positioning key as you scour the area
for supplies in most cases though it's
best to avoid combat altogether supplies
are limited in fragile bottles for
example can be used as weapons but will
break after one attack and since the
bigger enemies take more than one hit to
kill your best bet is to stay out of
their way and make for a quick exit
there's also an element of stealth to
encounters if you leave the car running
the monsters will hear you if you move
to breathe the monsters will hear you
and of course if you fight a monster or
break a bottle the monsters will hear
you because only dogs can fight back
empty-handed you need to be quiet and
plan your approach defensively if you do
manage to clear a path to the exit you
can hop in your car and escape as long
as you have enough gas from here you are
taken to a world map where you can pick
your next destination most of the time
you are given two options some of these
places are high-risk and offer better
rewards while others are safe but have
fewer resources while others may have
survivors which can either be a deadly
encounter or a safe haven managing
resources in planning your moves becomes
crucial should I send Steven out to
fetch more gas while Andrew leaves the
car running or should they go together
will Hillary have enough time to grab
that med kit before the monster catches
her my car only fits three and I have
four survivors
who do I leave behind
these are the kind of questions you'll
be asking yourself every step of the way
you'll be constantly weighing the risks
against the rewards and if you misjudge
a situation that could be the end of
your run if you make a wrong turn and
your team gets killed off you're forced
to start from the beginning but the game
truly shines the further along you get
you get more and more desperate as the
monsters start to greatly outnumber your
team sometimes you have to leave a
survivor behind if you want the rest of
your group to survive you feel as though
you're barely scraping by and when you
do survive against all odds it's all the
more satisfying unfortunately you will
die this can be frustrating but because
characters locales and interactions are
all randomly generated every playthrough
has its own unique story and that means
there's always a good reason to keep
playing if this game sounds interesting
to you you can pick it up in first
access at Overland - game comm for $20
the full release is still aways out but
it's definitely worth keeping an eye on
and if you've tuned in every day this
week from my indie mix coverage thank
you so so much we love doing this kind
of stuff and we can't do it without you
if you enjoyed this video or maybe one
of the other indie mix videos consider
subscribing it really helps us out thank
you and until next time
[Music]